are we insane I think we've been insane
for a very long time and this is kind of
like the peak of insanity
[Music]
[Music]
we're making something that we've never
done before we're gonna test and shoot a
spaghetti stuffed meatballs I'm really
nervous first and foremost because I've
hyped this up so much for months that
everyone is really looking forward to
seeing the outcome and I'm nervous about
not being able to deliver at all I'm
worried that the meatballs not gonna
hold together or hold its shape in the
oven I don't want it to like flatten out
like a pancake meatball yeah I think
that's about all that could go wrong but
we shall see so I figured I just bought
a ton of meat we're gonna try and dry
him turtle we're out of meat I think the
best way to start is to just take a
standard meatball recipe and make the
entire batch at one big meatball okay so
I'm doing a mix of sausage and ground
beef I'm gonna do two pounds total and
see if that's enough I'm gonna keep most
of it the same the only thing I'm gonna
change is adding some more bread crumbs
because I feel like that might help it
stick together a little bit more also
I'm gonna try stuffing the meatball with
cheese and spaghetti there's nothing
wrong with a little extra cheese that's
kind of the way I try to live my life
sometimes I like fall asleep and I just
wake up with like foods in my head and I
think this was one of them it better
work okay I think this is about ready oh
my gosh I'm really nervous it explodes
wouldn't be the first time I've had
something explode in the oven so my
thought is I'm going to line this bowl
with a bunch of plastic wrap and kind of
like line it with the meat and guide it
into a ball okay
I'm gonna spray it with cooking spray so
it doesn't stick
we'll get the meat in and I'm gonna push
it up the side oh my god there's a
little scarier than I thought I'd be
okay
this seems slightly sturdy I'm gonna
wash my hands okay so I'm gonna put the
cheese on the bottom because I feel like
it's less likely to leak out if it's not
at like the seam of where I'm closing
this and I'm just gonna be pretty
generous with the mozzarella okay so
we're gonna get a little pile of
spaghetti oh [ __ ]
Oh God okay okay I think that's enough
I'm gonna because I can open it back up
if it's not enough or too much come
together okay I put too much spaghetti
and not enough meat I don't think I
spread my meat thinly enough just try to
get this together it's gonna happen it's
gonna you know if the meatball doesn't
work we'll do a meat bowl okay come on
come together a little guy if you talk
to your food and encourage it it's more
likely to do what you want
protip this is definitely the size I was
going for I'm almost there this is
actually coming together
oh okay it's popping okay come on out
here we go honestly I feel decent about
this why to see this do you think this
is big enough
right do you think I should wrap it in
foil before I bake it or do you think I
can make it just like that it's coming
it's it's cooperating
that's it together I feel like this
shape is what I'm going for because I
want people to be able to slice it and
get the spaghetti from the middle we're
just gonna pop it in the oven I don't
know exactly what temperature you're
supposed to do for a super-sized
meatballs so I'm doing 375 and I'm just
gonna keep checking on it I feel like
it'll take at least 40 minutes I'm gonna
treat it like a meatloaf almost bake it
like you were baking a meatloaf and then
it'll be baked all the way through I
trust myself I think I did an okay job
and so I'm gonna pop this in the oven
[Music]
it's working yeah oh my god knock on
wood seriously look at that okay
a moment of truth I think it's ready
let's see Oh God a little cheese started
to leak out okay it's okay we'll cover
it with sauce nobody has to know okay
okay it's done how do I move it on new
boy okay hey I'm not so sure
[Music]
wait I might cry so we're gonna sauce it
I don't know how much to ladle huh I
just wanted to look sexier okay yep I
was not expecting that to work yeah oh
god I'm so nervous
Alexis will you just slice it I'm scared
how does it feel okay oh my god is there
gonna be a cheese pulp there's gonna be
a cheese wholeness a little advice I
swear I mean my mind yep oh my god oh my
gosh
[Laughter]
I didn't think this would taste good I
thought I'd just look cool it's good oh
my god it's like embarrassing how proud
I am okay time to make a video
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ready I'm so scared I'm so I'm so bad at
my job
okay really good that's a wrap
[Music]